[Music]
opponents of heater expansions celebrate
as the appeal court rules the decision
to approve a third runway was unlawful
because the government failed to
consider its commitments under the paris
climate Accord those bringing the case
including London Mayor Sadiq Khan said
it should be the end of the road
I'm not calling on the government not to
review that its plans for runway 3 but
to abandon their plans for runway 3 the
court said the third runway could go
ahead if it's proved to be compatible
with wider government climate policy
which includes cutting carbon emissions
the net zero but tellingly
the government says it will not appeal
and Boris Johnson who once said he'd lie
in front of the bulldozers may be
quietly celebrating this defeat Heathrow
is not and say they will appeal those in
the government to press ahead without
expanding our hub airport we will be
flying through someone else's hard Paris
Amsterdam Frankfurt in order to get to
global markets that is how serious this
is to the future of the UK the
communities in the path of the proposed
runway this is at least a stay of
execution campaigners say it's a turning
point we have to have all sectors
playing their part climate change is
real it's happening it's affecting
people now and we have to take action
for residents of some of the 700 homes
under threat there is relief whether or
not it will be the end of Appeals after
appeal not repeal I don't know but
certainly at the moment it's really good
positive news this judgement is a
stunning victory for these campaigners
but it is also a landmark ruling that
could affect major infrastructure
projects for decades
it turns the rhetoric around carbon
reduction into a concrete case law
lawyers say the judgement makes climate
change a priority for all future
development it's a real moment in the UK
particularly to see the Paris agreement
having this kind of impact domestically
and I think it's actually a moment
beyond the UK I think other countries
will be looking at this and realizing
actually the Paris agreement has impact
you know in domestic courts in real hard
cases the government says it remains
committed to increasing air capacity but
wherever it chooses airport expansion
will be harder to get off the ground
Paul Kelso Sky News